MALE SPEAKER: The name
"Pocket Gems" really speaks
to what we do, which is
make beautiful things
for your mobile device.
We try to make games
that appeal to everybody.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Innovation
in mobile gaming
right now is really important.
The social aspect to it seems
to be really, really important.
It's more engaging.
People love to be able to
interact with other people.
"War Dragons" was our
first online gameplay.
So server scalability
is really important.
In minutes or hours, you might
have hundreds of thousands
of players playing your game.
If you don't have the
server infrastructure,
your server is just
going to explode.
Google Cloud Platform
allows us to be
able to scale automatically.
We don't even have
to think about that.
If it needs more server,
it spins up servers.
When it doesn't
need them anymore,
it just spins them down
in a matter of seconds.
MALE SPEAKER: Our game
has evolved drastically
from the time of launch.
And we used Google App Engine
to build AB testing tools
where we could put out
different features as we
saw what people engaged
with and what they wanted.
Google App Engine and the
analytic tools behind it
were able to help us make
really good decisions on how
to evolve the game
over time as a service.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
Google Cloud Platform
allows us to focus
on what we love,
doing the best games we
can, the games that are
going to delight our players.
Your back end just works.
It's almost magical.
MALE SPEAKER: "Pocket
Gems" is really excited
be part of this
revolution, where
a billion people's first
experience with the internet
and with mobile is playing
products like ours.
It's a real privilege to
be making our products
being the ones that are out
there bringing on this change.
[MUSIC PLAYING]